we love this deal we thought the steel
really worked it's not something we're
excited about you're gonna see that for
sure
it'll be the same format except we have
the obvious which is two new great
pinch-hitting coaches and Shakira and
usher that's Cee Lo and Christina are
going to take a little time off these
guys are you know world-renowned
musicians first and you know America's
favorite TV coaches second so we knew
there'd be some shuffling going on but
um Blake and Adam are here for season
four and it's just exciting well you got
a man crush on rusher so he's left me
for us right now stuff he gets to spend
a season making ocean feel comfortable
that's great and I think I'm doing a
really good job of that by the way I've
said and done about everything I can
that crosses the line yeah and but you
know what I'll say this here we go
crossing that line you know isn't as
much as it you know I thank you that you
know he's cute and you know I've got the
Matt the bromance with Usher a little
bit I always know who to come home to
you know the one thing we always kind of
say is there's there's no replacing the
initial chemistry that could kind of
launch the show in this chatt asphere
and and it's bittersweet because as well
as everything's going with the new guys
you know it's kind of like one of those
things where you never get to enjoy the
ride up especially the live shows the
performances you know because none of us
mm-hmm
would know too much about what was
happening but CeeLo I mean he just does
live better than anybody and like what
they did love as a battlefield and it's
always fun to see what see those gonna
bring to the live shows because he that
guy thrives in performances but it's
costuming and he has you know just like
little people running around and flames
and you know all sorts of the games of
Thrones it's just it's nice all of this
is made up yeah yeah because it takes a
second you can't just come in and
immediately know how it we're all works
right and then yeah we definitely I'm
sitting next to cheek here so I gave her
some tips and things like that well it's
all in fun you know we want
so to be great so we have informed them
about certain things and how to handle
them they started getting really
comfortable towards the end of the
blinds and so I think that it's just
going to continue to evolve and become
as everybody gets more comfortable with
it
I honestly think shakira is maybe the
most competitive person on the on the
show I mean just because I think she she
feels that that disadvantage being you
know the only female on the show and she
definitely you can tell she has feels
like she has something to prove
are you gonna do voice again I'm pretty
sure that's gonna happen I would be I'd
be surprised if he didn't I'm so excited
I can't wait it's a lifelong you gotta
get all the originals for the moist
guess that way they'll flats all into
New York and we can be there and if I
can't then I'll get well maybe we'll get
bill hater to play you okay maybe we'll
get a push we get to play Blake Franco
Fred Fred Armisen maybe play you Kristin
Wiig have you ever seen the show it's a
sketch comedy show and is a cast that's
every week it's their scene Adam
Sandler's on that show oh no we're safe